hey everybody uh it's 2023 and I really
really wanted to send out a positive
message at the beginning of the year but
um recent events have made that
impossible
um
don't get me wrong I loved spirited it's
it's great maybe we had a blast the
entire family watched it I love will I
love Octavia obviously I did the
greatest showman with with benj and
Justin they're incredible and I loved
their music
uh and good afternoon by the way the
song Good afternoon I laughed the entire
way through it is absolutely brilliant
however
just heard the Academy have shortlisted
good afternoon in the best song category
now
Ryan Reynolds getting a nomination
in the best song category would make the
next year of my life insufferable
it would I mean I have to spend a year
with him shooting Wolverine and Deadpool
and it
trust me it would be impossible it'd be
a problem so but just to recap love
spirited love will love Octavia love the
song Good afternoon love benj and Justin
but please
please from the bottom of my heart
do not validate Ryan Reynolds in this
way
please